what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
this is my statistics tutorial series
where I give you all the applied
statistics knowledge that you need to
conquer the data science world in my
last video in this statistics tutorial
series I talked about confidence
intervals and how a lot of times in
applied work you will get asked to
estimate some kind of unknown quantity
but a lot of clients they don't want to
see just a point estimate they want to
see an interval estimate and that way
they understand how uncertain you are
about that estimate if you haven't seen
that video yet I highly recommend
watching that one before this one there
will be a card for it up above as well
as a link in the description now the
other tool for learning about unknown
quantities is hypothesis testing in my
confidence interval video I used an
example of Americans and how often they
use their phones on a daily basis so
let's just use the same example here and
let's suppose you hear on the news
somewhere that using your phone for more
than three-and-a-half hours a day is bad
for you let's say it causes cancer or
something like that so you want to
conduct a statistical test to
demonstrate that in fact Americans use
their phones for less than three and a
half hours a day so you create a sample
of 50 Americans let's just say it's a
perfectly random and representative
sample in this case and you come back
with a sample mean x-bar of 3.2 hours
and a sample standard deviation s of 1.2
hours and then immediately your question
should be statistically can we conclude
that the average time Americans spend on
their phones on a daily basis is in fact
less than 3.5 hours and hypothesis
testing is geared to answer questions
exactly like these so we're going to
walk through all the steps of this
problem but just keep in mind as we go
along
all hypothesis test is is just a
probability calculation that uses
real-world data
naturally the devil is in the details
and there's a little bit more convention
and formality than just that but at the
end of the day that's really all it is
that we're doing so these are the
following steps to a hypothesis testing
problem first of all we're going to
define a null hypothesis an alternative
hypothesis and a significance level
after that we're going to calculate a
test statistic third of all we're going
to use that test statistic to calculate
a p-value and then in our last step
we're going to compare that p-value to
our significance level alpha you're
either going to reject or fail to reject
the null hypothesis and then you're
gonna make a real-world conclusion so
let's walk through each one of these
steps first step we have defining the
null hypothesis the alternative
hypothesis and the significance level
starting with a significance level here
that's very closely related to the
confidence level that you would select
if you're making a confidence interval
in fact the significance level is
represented by the symbol alpha and the
confidence level is represented by 1
minus alpha now as far as the hypotheses
are concerned these are statements about
a parameter we represent the null and
alternative hypotheses with H naught for
the null and then H a or H 1 you'll
sometimes see it written for the
alternative hypothesis now let's
actually start with the alternative
hypothesis first and that's whatever it
is that we're trying to demonstrate by
using the statistical test in the first
place in our example we actually wanted
to demonstrate that the population mean
hours Americans use their phones is less
than 3.5 hours so we're going to set up
H a as mu smaller than 3.5 the null
hypothesis is just the opposite of
whatever the alternative hypothesis is
so here we can write mu equals 3.5
although technically the opposite is mu
is greater than or equal to 3.5 so you
can write either one of those down it
doesn't matter we have the null and the
alternative hypotheses written down
we're going to use alpha equals point
zero five for our significance level
just because point O five is
conventional and it's standard and then
BAM we're done on to step two now in
step two we have to calculate a test
statistic and all this is is a quantity
that describes how extreme the results
of your data are in one way or another
now we use a statistical distribution
here the same way we do with tons of
other probability calculations now what
we're doing here is a probability
calculation about a population mean and
in virtually all these instances you
don't know the population variance or
population standard deviation either so
in all of these instances we use a T
distribution the theoretical reason for
that is a subject for a different video
but the long and short of it is that in
the overwhelming majority of problems
involving a population mean you will use
a t distribution however in instances
involving a population proportion you'll
use a Z statistic from a normal 0 1
distribution so in our case here we
calculate a T statistic the T statistic
for a one sample t-test is just equal to
X bar minus mu naught over the standard
error of X bar where the standard error
of X bar equals s divided by the square
root of n so if we just plug all our
numbers from our example in here we get
T equals 3.2 minus 3 point 5 divided by
one point two over the square root of 50
which gives us negative one point seven
six seven seven haven't you've
calculated your test statistic you're
going to move on to step three which is
where you use the distribution of that
test statistic to calculate what's
called a p-value and now I'm going to
have a whole video on what a p-value is
and is not
but the short definition of it is that a
p-value is the probability you observe a
test statistic as extreme or more
extreme than you did assuming the null
hypothesis
in fact true for finding the p-value you
can use a t-distribution table of which
there's tons of them out there or you
can use our I personally like using our
so that's what we're gonna do here and
the p-value is going to be the area to
the left of t equals negative one point
seven six seven seven why because when
we talk about more extreme that means in
the direction of the alternative
hypothesis we have a left-sided test
here that is the alternative is that mu
is less than three point five so the
p-value is the area on the left side of
the statistic as well that is the area
to the left using a t-distribution with
49 degrees of freedom of t equals
negative one point seven six seventy
seven now we go into r and we use an
appropriate probability function and we
find that the p-value is point zero four
one seven now if we want to relate that
p-value into our problem that means that
the probability that we would observe a
result as extreme or more extreme than
we did if in fact the null hypothesis
was true is only point zero four one
seven now that's a pretty low
probability in step four lastly we're
gonna compare that p-value we just
calculated to our significance level
that we picked at the beginning of this
exercise if the p-value is less than
alpha we're going to reject the null
hypothesis if the p-value is greater
than alpha we're going to fail to reject
the null hypothesis point zero four one
seven is less than 0.05 so in our case
here we reject the null hypothesis and
our conclusion is there is statistically
significant evidence based on the test
that we just did that the true average
number of hours that Americans spend on
their phones daily is less than 3.5
hours now let's suppose that we found a
p-value that was greater than 0.05 well
in that instance we would say that we
fail to reject this null hypothesis and
you may be asking yourself ok that's
some really negative
which that we've got going on here we've
got reject the null versus fail to
reject the null why don't we talk about
accepting either the null or the
alternative well you have to be really
careful with that language because a
hypothesis test really does not prove
anything
all hypothesis test is really doing is
trying to assess by counterexample if it
seems to be likely that the null
hypothesis is false your example may not
have demonstrated it to be false but
even if you don't reject the null
hypothesis your test isn't set up to
demonstrate that the null hypothesis is
necessarily true either another related
point is if we get all this wrong so
again we calculated a p-value of 0.001 7
so the probability we observe something
as extreme or more extreme than we did
if the null hypothesis is true is 0.04
1/7 because that's such a low
probability we decide it's more likely
the null hypothesis isn't true and we
reject it however based on the same test
there is still that point 0 4 1 7 chance
that this would have happened even if
the null hypothesis were true so we
would have rejected the null hypothesis
even if it's actually true and we would
have made a mistake now this is what's
called a type 1 error the probability of
a type 1 error is represented by alpha
and it's the probability that we reject
the null hypothesis if it's actually
true this is the exact same thing as the
significance level and we select this at
the beginning based on how serious the
consequences of such an error are now in
the other direction it could be the case
that the null hypothesis is actually
false but we end up with a p-value of
greater than alpha and then we fail to
reject it even when it's false this is
what's called a type 2 error the
probability of a type 2 error is the
probability that we fail to reject the
null hypothesis when the null hypothesis
is actually false and this probability
is represented by the character beta
there's a related quantity 1 minus beta
and that's the statistical power
of the test that is that's the chance
that you correctly reject the null
hypothesis if it's actually false
but type 1 and type 2 errors and power
are a full topic in and of themselves
and that's a subject for a different
video so it include this is an overview
of the hypothesis testing framework and
the steps which will go into any
hypothesis testing problem this is part
of a three part series on this topic the
next part will cover p-values in greater
detail and then the next part after that
we'll cover type 1 type 2 errors and
statistical power so thanks for watching
this video if you enjoyed it and you'd
like to support my work the best thing
that you could do for me would be to
share this video otherwise please
consider smashing the like button and
then I'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then Richard on
data